[Musique]
notre ca ce soir comme tous les mardis
avec jean luc landry et jean martin
aussant bonsoir bonsoir à tous et jean
martin fallait-il ouvrir la frontière
aujourd'hui ben je pense que vos
téléspectateurs très bien résumé la
chose ça m'inquiète pas tellement parce
que les gens qui vont pouvoir rentrer
sont ceux qui sont les mieux préparés
donc pleinement vacciner puis si ça peut
aider l'économie dans plusieurs secteurs
à rouvrir incluant tourisme qui est un
secteur très important moi je ne vois
pas d'inquiétude en notant que c'est
bien fait et qu'on laisse effectivement
entrer des gens qui sont vaccinées jean
lieu que vous en pensez quoi
la crise c'est ce que j'en attends viens
de mentionner en état que c'est bien
fait et jusqu'ici ça semble bien
ça fait assez minime et l'eau et il ya
eu des gens qui ont vu sa passe et qui
ont affecté alors oui ouvrir mais il ya
un travail à part que les deux on serait
bien des gens soient pied vacciner deux
fois et damas qui est arrivé je vous
mentionne simplement qu'il ya eu 100
on a fait pendant le mois d'août à la
frontière est haut dans les aéroports on
a fait des tests et il 112 cas positifs
sur 50 quelques 1000 tests effectués à
la frontière donc le taux de positivité
chez les personnes vaccinées qui se
présentent à la frontière est
extrêmement faible présentement je vous
fais entendre le pdg de l'alliance de
l'industrie touristique du québec martin
soucy qui lui espère que le tourisme va
revenir en l'écoutant l'espérance
actuellement c'est que ça puisse
repartir progressivement on s'attend pas
à des miracles à court terme on pense
que 2022 en fonction aussi de la mariée
en plus on est loin puis faut qualifier
son voyage donc cette variable aux
barbades influence d'importance et de
rester en tête de liste des destinations
à voyager dans le futur pour les marchés
où on s'adresse par exemple les français
on a très hâte de pouvoir les revoir au
québec alors est ce que jean-luc penser
quand on peut s'attendre à une reprise
relativement rapide dans le secteur du
tourisme vous pensez que ça va prendre
plusieurs années pour revenir là où nous
étions
je pense que plusieurs années mais
certainement des mois et donc
la personne que visiteur 10,8 alors
parlé de l'année prochaine alors plus
tard l'année prochaine on va être
revenue à la normale oubliez pas que à
long terme le touriste un manque et je
sais pas si vous avez talent et j'ai
pris l'avion d'un dernier à lille il n'y
a pas une allure ans qui sont en
construction en extension alors très
clairement on va retrouver le goût de
voyager on va le faire mais je suis
d'accord avec monsieur leubou quand il
mentionne que vos places habitués bon
ok je vous fais entendre tout de suite
puisque vous êtes d'accord je fais
entendre que monsieur legault a dit un
peu plus tôt
va falloir apprendre à vivre avec le
virus ça veut dire que
pour un bon bout de temps
va falloir accepter
un certain rythme on veut pour confiner
ça veut dire qu'il va falloir par un bon
boutin accepté qui va avoir des
personnes qui vont être hospitalisée
pour la copier
on est rendu là jean martin il faut
accepter ça comme le dit le premier
ministre bien sûr l'acceptent pas on est
dans le déni parce que le virus est là
puissent être même risque selon certains
experts que ce soit saisonniers knox que
c'est reviennent chaque année dans une
mesure moindre on l'espère avec le
vaccin mais c'est vrai qu'il faut
s'habituer à vivre avec ça je pense que
ça se fait quand même assez bien mais
quelques groupes récalcitrants puis un
peu plus bruyant mais je pense que c'est
une infime portion des populations et
heureusement et qu'en général la
population comprend que c'est un effort
collectif au bénéfice des collectivités
est ce qu'on fait pas assez jean-luc
l'économie tout à coup avant en tenant
des propos comme ceux en disant on va
accepter que le virus reste qui est des
gens à l'hôpital qui est des gens aux
soins intensifs on va par confiner
il ya une paire vers cette attention le
virus est dangereux et c'est le fait que
les gens être ou pas et ils conviennent
pas une vie normale est-ce qu'on fait
penser l'économie à grands noms que je
pense et la qualité vie d'avant le
moment donné ils vont pas embaucher ou
sinon alors leur tête qu on fait tourner
la machine on a un bon système pour
détecter on va s'habituer
si on attend on se remémore un sujet
méconnu en fait voilà il faut commencer
à s'habituer quand vous relate la
plongée vous plongez
s'habitue ok on verra la suite de toute
façon ce qui va se passer dans le réel
option consommateurs
a fait plusieurs recommandations
aujourd'hui pourtant très tenté de
contrer la pression de l'inflation sur
les finances des canadiens et donc faire
des suggestions aux partis politiques il
ya plusieurs
des des promotions qui visent les
banques qui font des profits
substantiels des options consommateurs
pendant que le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs pâtit avec la crise est-ce
qu'on a raison de vouloir serrer la vis
des banques jean martin les profits
substantiels vous êtes poli les banques
font des profits quand même assez
astronomiques et c'est vrai que pour un
consommateur qui voit ses frais annuels
passer quelques centaines de dollars
quand la banque fait des dizaines de dir
ou quand les banques font des dizaines
de milliards de profits collectivement
on se demande c'est quoi la portion des
profits qui vient vraiment des petits
frais relativement petit mais fatigante
qui parle d'un compte des gens parce que
les banques en fait foi leur argent avec
ce qu'on appelle trading desk en bon
français ou les activités sur intérêts
l'activité de dépôt et de prêt donc je
pense que la portion qui hérite vraiment
un consommateur sait pas qu'elle fasse
de l'argent sur le trading desk
séquelles charge des frais par dessus
les milliards de profits qu'elles font
donc je pense que pourrait considérer
mois enlevé les frais d'opération aux
usagers aujourd'hui d'accord avec sa
jolie très moi j'en ai tous contre les
les huit aux intéressés les cas de crise
oui c'est toujours y trouver que c'est
vastement exagéré absolument pas de se
faire surtout que ce sont les gens les
plus bas prix qui pèse 1,1 million bon
ballon à la proposition générale ce qui
permettait à tous les relations pas si
fort que soi
n'hérite pas des grandes interventions
musclées lorsqu'on sait que il a
augmenté de façon temporaire parce que
des pénuries les leucémies papier nagy
stewart ou encore et donc la 3d
également s'attendre à ce que le taux
d'inflation rebelles certains pensent
qu'ils vont merci très bas donc ils vont
mais si simple mais tout le monde sent
pas qu il ya une période d'ajustement
pour les haussiers des banques l'époque
elles ont de larges
gestes mentionné un point là tout le
monde est d'accord avec le fait que le
niveau fédéral
pourrait une proposition du parti
d'augmenter les impôts sur les bénéfices
des banques dans un monopole quand vous
augmenter les taxes c'est le
consommateur qui paye alors ce que vous
allez là je vous donne un autre exemple
de taxes que personne n'a mentionné
c'est dans les cellulaires avec la vente
des 3g on vient de fer frappés d'une
taxe de 8 milliards de dollars lorsque
c'est le consommateur qui va payer parce
que c'est sûr qu'un monopole une
oligopole comme celui des cellulaires
qui à peu près équivalent 7 des ventes
si le consommateur elle a fait d'argent
liquide est donc la 5g effectivement
vous m'amenez sur le secteur décideurs
et du marché des télécommunications va
parler d'une proposition du parti
libéral sur la surtaxe des banques
jean-luc le parti conservateur propose
d'ouvrir le marché des
télécommunications à la concurrence
étrangère pour faire baisser les prix
est-ce qu'on fait ça jean martin mais
moi j'ai une préférence pour que ce soit
les canadiens qu'ils fassent l'argent là
dessus donc j'aime bien les compagnies
locales sur à tous points de vue mais il
suffit d'avoir vécu à l'étranger pour se
rendre compte à quel point ces chers ici
moi j'ai eu la chance de vivre cinq ans
en angleterre puis si la moitié sinon le
tiers du prix de ce qu'on fait ici pour
les mêmes services parfois même des
services meilleur parce que plus de
concurrence ben j'ai peut-être
concurrence oui certainement parce qu en
europe et plusieurs opérateurs mais je
pense qu'ici au canada si ça va pas vers
une réglementation avec un prix plafond
il va falloir ouvrir à la concurrence
parce qu'il ya aucune raison pour
laquelle on payer plus cher qu'ailleurs
dans ces mesures jean-luc là dessus mais
l'argument jean martin et ses réponses
si on suit la faudrait que toutes les
entreprises canadiennes ont produit tout
ce qui se fait au canada parce que
beaucoup à l appliquer ce principe là
seulement aux cellules a donc oui à
force de manger vous
exactement même pas frontières aussi à
l'étranger et d'ailleurs ce qu'on veut
contrôler la cie la culture le contenu
le tuyau alors le tuyau lui
n'est pas ce qui peut le faire sans et
plus on se repose la culture c'est la
même chose dans le système aérien vous
avez vous empêcher les étrangers et on a
des tarifs aériens qui sont le double
des états unis je vous arrête des six
nations l'horloge s'arrête si on va
reprendre ce débat la paix merci
beaucoup à ma vie
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh